on va voir aujourd'hui une façon simple
et efficace de décortiquer la première
étape c'est d'enlever les deux fins
incluant les avant bras
c'est important de casser à l'envers des
articulations ont relevé le coffre comme
si on enlevait out de charge
on va dégager ensuite les alvéoles qui
sont à la base des pâtes
dans la paume de la main écrasée la
queue on pousse à l'intérieur de la
carapace et la chaire va sortir sans
forcer et a pas de gaspillage là c'est
important de dégager la pince des
avant-bras léger mouvement de
va-et-vient de façon à ce que le liquide
qui est emprisonné dans la pince puisse
sortir on va faire une légère incision
et faire un petit mouvement sec et la
pince vacances et immédiatement il va
nous rester les avant bras qui sont
situées en fait entre les pins c'est le
corps durement avec le couteau de chef
c'est très facile de séparer ses trois
sections sans forcer et ensuite avec une
petite fourchette à omar dégager la
chair qui est coincé à l'intérieur et ça
c'est vraiment à mon goût le meilleur
morceau du moment ensuite les pattes on
coupe vraiment juste un petit peu avant
la jointure et à l'aide d'une paille on
pousse à l'intérieur de la carapace et
la chaire va sortir sans forcer et a pas
de gaspillage l'a ensuite faire un
mouvement rotatif pour dégager les trois
nageoires qui sont au bout de la queue
du home à dresser votre assiette
une présentation la plus conviviale
possible et puis rendre vos invités hall
[Musique]